Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and today me and Jake we're
gonna finish our bunk bed Bushcraft
shelter we're also going to eat some
amazing food and have a great time doing
it
[Music]
oh there's tons of bunny tracks here
Jake that's where the bunnies have eaten
the bark off the tree that's what they
eat in the wintertime
I can see it we're almost there
all right we made it and looks like some
animals have been visiting this is a
moose track from only a day ago so many
rabbit tracks here let's see if they
went inside yeah there was a bunny went
inside our Fort we had house guests
you know that's pretty hard to do with
snowshoes on there Jake
there we go now go try that ladder and
now you're climbing it like a champ why
don't you use the shovel clean off the
snow there
foreign
well our shelter looks like it's in
pretty good shape me and Jake are just
gonna kind of knock the snow off and get
things organized and then I've got a few
improvements I'm gonna make I got a plan
in mind I'm gonna need seven small trees
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
are you getting cold Jacob yeah do you
want to get in your sleeping bag yeah
get some Caribou hides down
there we go
these snowy boots off
get yourself all warmed up get down deep
in that sleeping bag
yeah
you want me to get your blankie okay
there you go ah Jacob's such a trooper
he's been following me around in his
snowshoes for the last two hours but his
fingers are all cold so I threw him in a
sleeping bag gave him some toys in his
blankie he's good to go if you're gonna
take kids out in this weather have a
good sleeping bag a good sleeping bag
can fix a lot of problems
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
all right well the shelter's looking
pretty good I just need some final
touches I really need a chair in there
foreign
all right
all right now that we've got that done I
think we need to get some firewood
chopped up
foreign
Sun's starting to set time to get out
our lamps
oh now they got my lights on I think I
need to get a little organized here this
is a bit of a mess
oh there we go
oh this Fire's just barely started it's
already warming up the shelter just
concentrates that heat so well
I got wet and stacked some logs up in
between the fire and the heat reflector
one it'll help dry out my wood so it'll
burn better and two it'll kind of
protect my heat reflector from catching
on fire until I get the fire dialogue
then there we go now we're cooking with
gas
oh is this warm
yeah
you like the trail mix bud
yeah you're probably pretty hungry huh I
got a little boy who told me he's hungry
so we're gonna go ahead and get a hot
dog going
that's a good looking hot dog
the white bellied Jacob hides in his
burrow and eats his prey
you like your hot dog
all right it's time to start cooking
some dinner and I've got this big cube
of butter here with rosemary basil and
garlic in there and we're gonna just sit
this by the fire and let it get all
melty and mixed together
well I got a sweet potato here now I've
split it long ways and put cinnamon
butter inside and wrapped it in tin foil
we're gonna throw it on the coals and
let this thing slow cook until it's nice
and soft
you getting too hot Jake
there we go
here's your slippers
you know these little Camp booties are
nice all right
are you hungry yeah I'll get you some
crab legs well the sweet potato is
almost done so I think it's time to
start cooking the main course
king crab legs look at these things
check out this is just one king crab leg
it's over two feet long look how thick
that is too so much meat on these things
they're so delicious now you think about
crab legs they're always pre-cooked so
all you got to do is just heat them up
and eat them I take my pot holder
ah
look at this massive joint
oh that is a solid piece of meat right
there
dip that in the rosemary garlic butter
oh that's so good
hmm there's so much meat on these crabs
that one knuckle was like a whole
lobster tail
look at this
oh
yeah look at that sweet potato oh
that sweet potato is good
got a piece of cornbread for you too
oh okay
things are on the outside with crabs
take a little bit of this meat
okay
a little butter on there king crab sweet
potato and Cornbread you ready
yeah yeah you can hold it
[Music]
there we go look at that plate of food
oh so good
hmm
that rosemary butter is so good
mmm
oh I just inhaled that I just ate two
pounds of king crab legs and I could eat
two more that was so fabulous king crab
has to be one of my favorite things to
eat up here in Alaska and if all goes
well here in a couple months I'm gonna
go catch my own it's gonna be nice well
guys I got a belly full of food and I am
exhausted so I'm gonna go ahead and get
my bed ready and get into my sleeping
bag but uh it's way too hot in here I've
got to go put this fire down otherwise
I'm gonna roast tonight
thank you
all right
oh my socks are kind of sweaty so I'm
gonna take my socks off and stick them
in the bottom of my bags to dry I want
to put on these slippers keep my feet
warm if you get cold feet at night
getting a pair of these down booties oh
they're so nice and they weigh almost
nothing and take almost no room in your
bag
all right guys it's late it's time for
bed I'll see you guys in the morning
all the sun's up but I am slow getting
up and at them it's nice and toasty in
my bag oh this is the hardest part of
winter camping
oh I'm so brave
when you first start the fire it just
fills the thing with smoke
once the Fire gets hot though it clears
the Smoke Out
there we go I'm gonna warm my boots up a
lot of ice on the inside of this tarp
snowed just a little bit last night
there's a lot of condensation and ice on
this tarp how are we doing all these are
all nice and toasty
oh my socks are nice and warm and dry
well since I'm up and about I'm gonna go
ahead and put my sleeping bag away don't
want it falling in the fire or smelling
like smoke
melting sleeping bags has been a problem
lately
well now that I got things straightened
up in here a little bit I think it's
time to start making some breakfast
hey good morning Jacob good morning
Daddy you hungry
right now
Jake you want chocolate croissant I've
got hot chocolate to dip it in uh
and let me test it out make sure it's
good
mmm
you like that
all right guys for breakfast we're
having steel cut oatmeal
all right you got a lump of butter and
some brown sugar
there you go you're gonna have the rest
bud
all right
if I've said it once I've said it a
million times steel cut oatmeal is so
much better than instant oatmeal
um fills you up properly too
Hey Jake you like the oatmeal
[Music]
yeah it will oatmeal is an excellent
source of fiber
ah feels nice to have a belly full of
warm food well now that we got breakfast
out of the way I think I need to clean
up a little bit lace is getting messy
all right buddy
gets you
here get in there
Hey Jake you good yeah
all right we got Jacob loaded up
somewhere in there you cozy
[Music]
yeah I wish somebody would pull me in a
sled while snuggled in a sleeping bag
that'd be pretty nice
well I hope you guys had as much fun as
we did if you want to see more camping
Adventure videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning and check out our
camping and Adventure playlist I'll put
a link in the video description below
alright I'll see you guys next Saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]